foreign
hey everybody what's going on yeah
you're squeaking over here squeak you're
trying to move this chair I need to oil
it
oil okay
yeah yeah my chair is kind of like uh it
doesn't squeak but it makes kind of like
funny [ __ ] noises yeah
all right we were talking about uh in
the comment section we're talking about
the next uh haunting yeah for tomorrow
and uh talking about Ghost Soldier
go soldiers up my least favorite episode
but we probably do it anyway we'll
probably do it anyway yeah because I
think that's one of the few like old
ones that we haven't done yet yeah we'll
talk about it and it's better than
having to like dig through
and find one so yeah we probably will
okay tomorrow so
I gotta talk about the Godfather Part
Two finally got around to doing it I
feel really bad because uh it was Louis
wasn't it yeah Louise Louise sent us uh
all three of the good father movies yeah
Deluxe set of them yeah and so like we
did the first Godfather a long time ago
and I kept saying oh we really gotta get
around and do a part two and finally
finally finally got everybody but the
thing about it was that we got a little
bit of a late start last night and I
remember this movie was long I forgot
that it was three and a half hours long
yeah it's long so we got about two
hours-ish into it and I couldn't stay
awake anymore so we shut it down and we
finished it the next morning yeah so we
had to basically get up it's more like
we were still in bed and like watch the
watch again
just the timing was bad when we did it
but it's still it's a great movie
enjoyed it uh the first movie I think is
a masterpiece I liked it and this second
one I think was better I kind of think
so too like as amazing as they both are
I think a lot of people say that like
this one's better than the original I
think it might be as well more happens
in it there's a bunch of flashbacks to
veto Corleone when he was young
and played by um Robert De Niro back
when Robert De Niro was young
young and pretty he's a pretty boy
I forgot I didn't realize he was a
pretty boy when he was young he plays a
young veto Corleone how he came up how
he became the Godfather yeah who was
played by [ __ ] old West's name
[ __ ] Marlon Brando in the first one
shows how he came up how he killed a
dude killed a black hand enforcer and
how he became the Godfather protecting
his neighborhood so it's good it's got a
good backstory you know their flashbacks
are real good how he came to America
in the early 1900s and everything and
then it goes to his second son
the new Godfather Michael yeah Michael
Michael Corleone and everything that he
he has to go through
and um just the [ __ ] badass [ __ ]
story
yeah I really liked I the thing about
this movie is that this came out two
years after the original because the
original Godfather came out in 1972 and
then this one came out in 1974. now the
part of the movie that's uh veto
Corleone's backstory like how he came to
the United States and how he became the
Godfather and stuff that was from the
novel The Godfather but the stuff with
Michael Corleone like in the present day
which is 1958 uh was actually written by
uh Francis Ford Coppola and Mario Puzo
the novelist they got together and like
wrote Because Francis Ford Coppola
really liked the idea of having like a
parallel story he's like I really like
the idea of like a father and son at the
same age but like while Vito was coming
up and they were like you know this was
kind of like the the rise of the family
whereas like Michael was kind of like
the beginning of the downfall of the
family so he really liked those parallel
stories where they were like kind of
Crossing like that and I feel like when
this first came out
I mean I'm not saying that it's like
this got I wouldn't go so far as to say
this got mixed reviews this got like
pretty overwhelmingly positive reviews
and it won like a bunch of Oscar's best
picture Best Director all that kind of
stuff too but I feel like if there was
any criticism some people were like oh
well it should have just been the
Michael Corleone story because you
couldn't really get too much emotionally
invested because it kept switching back
and forth between the two stories but I
still agree well I feel like as a couple
of years went on I feel like it got like
a critical reassessment and to be honest
like I you very very rarely see anyone
criticizing anything about this movie
anymore it's basically seen as not only
one of the greatest American films ever
made but again like one of the examples
where uh you know the the sequel is
actually like better than although this
technically is a prequel and a sequel at
the same time
an interesting historical side note in
the [ __ ] history of [ __ ] American
military history
Saddam Hussein
the president of Iraq or dictator of
Iraq whatever you want to call him
his three major influences were Joseph
Stalin Adolf Hitler and these three
movies they said he loved these three
Godfather movies and evidently he read
the books too translated into into
Arabic
but um
those
two historical figures and this
fictional story is uh evidently what
Saddam Hussein had modeled himself after
he saw it as a training manual
and I can see what he's talking about
yeah I can see it yeah I can see that he
thought the Godfather movie series was a
[ __ ] great way of learning leadership
and how to forge loyalty
I could totally see it but he loved him
evidently he had pictures of those guys
on his desk
like it was his wife or something yeah
that's pretty weird yeah
well yeah well no he had he had it was a
mixture evidently it was pictures of
Adolf Hitler Joseph Stalin and then the
characters from these movies like
[ __ ] Don Corleone and [ __ ] Michael
Corleone so seriously if you walk into
somebody's office and those are the
pictures on their desk you might just
want to back away yeah yeah I should say
that's that's a giant red flag right
there
Tom Sykes says uh sucks Michael killed
his brother in this film uh also former
female drug kingpin Griselda Blanco
named her son Michael Corleone
yeah that's well the thing about it is
that Michael Corleone this is kind of
like his
his side of the story is kind of like
his moral downfall because the the irony
of his story was that he was the one
that didn't want to be like his father
even though he was
personality wise the most like his
father which is why uh that's why he was
chosen right even though he wasn't the
oldest but he didn't want to do it no
but the thing is you're misinter I think
you might be misinterpreting the ending
it wasn't a sad ending
Michael realized that he had taken the
same path that his dad took just because
he didn't want to do it didn't mean it
wasn't necessary because that's what
that's what that meant was is Mafia Dawn
leadership is the same as any other kind
of leadership you're going to kill
people every time you make decisions it
doesn't matter if you're the president
of the United States or any other
country every decision you make results
in some kind of death
and uh yeah he killed his brother but he
had to there was no there was another
joke well I mean from his Credo was a
traitor from his point of view it's like
yeah Freda was he was a security threat
to trade yeah I mean to be fair he was
kind of an idiot and maybe he was
telling the truth when he said oh I
didn't realize we did that but that's
what I'm saying it's like it it would
have been at least from his point of
view it would have been like a security
risk like to keep him around yeah and
that was the same with his wife Kay had
to go
although she didn't get killed she
didn't get killed they didn't have to
kill her yeah but she had to go he just
like chucked her out she had to go she
was a security threat
she's a risk should have betrayed him
so he gave the kids to Connie his sister
he could trust that's how that went down
Camp guy said I thought Fredo got it in
number three no he gets killed at the
end of this one and at number two well I
was fishing saying his Hail Marys yeah
cause that's how he would like catch a
fish and everything I was for a second I
hadn't seen this movie since I was a kid
probably or a teenager and you know how
they have that scene because you know
you just know that Fredo's gonna get it
like for a second you kind of think oh
maybe Michael like forgive him because
he kind of seems to but then I was like
I don't think he's going to no but then
there's that scene where Fredo is on the
dock with Anthony like Michael's son
yeah and they're talking and he's
telling him the whole thing about the
Hail Mary and that's why like he caught
the fish and everything and I said
wouldn't it be [ __ ] up if Michael made
his son Anthony who was what like 10 or
11 or something like kill right now like
as an initiation I don't think they'd go
there but I said that's I thought about
it for a second Fredo just thinking that
he was safe and that he had been
forgiven means he's a security threat
he's a security yeah
you're supposed to know no you're dead
you [ __ ] you you aligned yourself
with an enemy who [ __ ]
it didn't matter whether or not you you
knew that [ __ ] a hit was going to
happen you still lined yourself with it
with it with a possible enemy you should
have always assume the worst from an
animal he wasn't really that bright he
was stupid yeah and I think that that's
kind of why I really liked the scene
with Michael and Fredo like where Fredo
got like really mad because he was he
was older I mean he was the older
brother so he kind of felt like he
should have been the next one in
succession and he was like resentful
toward Michael for getting chosen over
him but the reason that Vito didn't
choose him was because like I said he
was kind of like he thought of him as
kind of weak or like not really that
bright yeah and what was great is that
they talked about this is all part of
the rules all right uh when they went to
go see what's his name in prison they
talked about you know you invented you
you modeled the the uh the mafia after
the Roman Empire with capos and soldiers
Frankie five Angels right and he says
and it worked you know well
a a mafia family is an army it's run
like a military
uh it's the same thing you know in an
infantry unit Airborne unit Ranger
Special Forces any weakness you are
eliminated whether you
meant it or not it doesn't matter if you
can't fraternize with the Enemy
that's that's a security violation
you're gone
you know yeah I mean just for a
pragmatics just fraternizing with them
is enough okay so no he had to go
he had to go he's a traitor well like I
said from
from Michael's standpoint in the movie
like yeah he had a bunch of people
killed but
You could argue that like a lot of the
people that he had killed like um they
tried to have him killed yes this is
what's called so this is what's called
in any business any government or
military business called goal directed
violence you're killing people
you're it's murder yeah cold-blooded but
it's to serve a higher function okay
it's to keep your Society together in
this case his Society is the mafia not
the United States not the Marines where
he came up he was an ex-marine it's not
it's his family and the mafia
that's what he's supporting
any violation results in death Fredo
thinking that he was forgiven is a sign
that he's weak he's got to go
had he been a real mafioso he would have
known there is no forgiveness for that
yeah he's like well I'm dead yeah
he should have done what the other guy
did he should have done like Frankie did
Frankie killed himself so his family
could be safe right which that was the
Roman way
yeah and that was like The Honorable way
I mean yeah like um you know [ __ ] uh
Hagen or whatever his name is like had
to come there and uh and say that that's
what it was hey you know how in the
Roman Empire like they all like slit
their wrist in the tub or something like
Madness in their fans were taken care of
and you know and they're like yeah yeah
and he was cool with that yeah that's
right yeah that's right he's down there
in his [ __ ] so like I said he knew
the score right because that was a sign
that you had atoned and that you weren't
a coward
so your family was forgiven
because I mean Frankie kind of
um got on their wrong side too
so because they were all kind of in on
the plot right Frankie was and uh and uh
Hyman Roth
the guy and Fredo they were all kind of
in on it yeah
the wife she just basically wanted to
leave
I don't she didn't know anything about
the assassination attempt because she
almost got killed too no she's just
chicken it out and she couldn't she
couldn't be well I couldn't keep her
cool well the thing about I mean to be
fair to K like to her character if you
remember in the first movie like I said
Michael didn't want anything to do with
being in the crime family he wanted to
go straight he wanted to go legit he
joined the military
um he wanted to have a normal life and
she kind of signed on to the marriage
and stuff like that with the
understanding that they would have a
normal life and not be in the crime
family and he even told her in the first
movie you know we're gonna go legit like
the business is gonna go legit in five
years and at the start of Godfather too
it's been seven years and that still
hasn't happened so he's gone back on his
promise so I think she kind of has every
right because she wasn't in the crime
family she like I said she didn't sign
on for that necessarily but so I can't
really blame her for like wanting to
leave
but you know the fact she kind of
I don't I don't know I don't know if I
want to say she did in a [ __ ] up way
but he didn't you know he didn't want
her to leave he basically wanted to keep
the kids there and he that's what he
ended up doing you know like especially
after she told him it's like hey I
didn't have a miscarriage I aborted your
kid well that's why she had to go yeah
because you know yeah well the Italians
are Catholics all right that was a
that's an Abomination and he wanted
another son yeah he already had a son
but he wanted another son yeah he had a
son he had to have a bunch of shots he
knows yeah because you got to have a
bunch to pick among yeah yeah you need
three or four of them because they're
not all going to be the same and one of
one of them three or four is going to be
better than the other than the other
ones
so you need to stable of sons to pick
from because there's an error rate
he knows exactly what's going on yeah
right
yeah that's why he was so excited about
her riding another one and she said oh
no we're not having more sons and he's
like oh you got to be replaced you're
out yeah
now I now I'm kind of interested I don't
think I've ever seen part three I think
I I don't think I've I think I've seen
it but I was young so I probably I I
know I don't remember anything of it I
mean I I was just watching a video
um on that and I think the channel is
called the vile I and he does videos
called analyzing evil and he picks like
fictional characters and he was doing
Michael Corleone and he talked about the
character like through all three movies
so he went a little bit into what
happened in part three as well but I
don't think I've ever seen it now
in in Michael's defense he couldn't
leave the mafia they couldn't go
straight there's just no way well nobody
can really like once you're here to do
so is to leave all your allies to the
mercies of your enemies
they because they have been fighting
your the mafia enemies
so where's their protection gonna come
from
they have to flip and become part of the
other families or flip allegiances and
it's just and and that's really gonna uh
[ __ ] up their incomes so hey so Michael
as a leader can't walk away from all
these guys he's got a keep him in money
and keep them safe
he's a captain of a ship he can't just
[ __ ] abandon the ship there's no way
he was born into it and it's been going
on for 2 000 years he's not going
anywhere
yeah in a lot of ways I kind of feel
like
that's what's almost I almost a little
bit tragic about his story is that in
the first movie you could tell that he
really wanted to be his own person and
he wanted to like get away and make his
own life but there really wasn't any way
of I mean he
so much of his life was like mapped out
for him and there wasn't really any way
to escape from that yeah but if you go
back and look at how vit how Vito came
about he had no choice either yeah I
think that's he didn't want to do that
which is I think why he chose Michael
yeah because Michael would be
indifferent towards it which he which
means that
he's not a guy who's seeking power it's
kind of thrust on him which means that
he's more trustworthy that's kind of
what I was thinking it's like because
because the fact that some of the other
ones wanted it and Michael didn't right
yeah anybody that wants power that's not
the person that you want to put in power
yeah exactly you know what I mean
exactly see so he's like The Reluctant
you can't this is history shows it over
and over again you cannot trust men that
seek power
and
um you can't trust weak men with power
and his other brothers were weak
well and particularly Sunny who got
killed in the first week he was just
real um hot-headed which is a form of
weakness yeah he can like be trusted
either right and he wasn't he was not
intellectual at all
so he just couldn't trust him and then
Freda was the opposite
he was kind of weasily weasily and and
weak willed and a little bit dumb dumb
he just so not very perceptible he can't
trust a weak man with power you you can
only trust a strong guy who doesn't
really want the power it's thrust on him
and it's responsibility it's a burden
and he's trying to
keep his team alive that's who you want
it's you know what I mean he doesn't
really want it all right his
it's a great movie and that that asked
me that's why Saddam liked this [ __ ] I
don't think Saddam wanted to be
president in a certain way and look at
his sons
his sons were [ __ ] up
and I really I mean I really liked I
kind of feel like you know the story
with Michael is kind of you know the the
heart of the movie but I also really
liked seeing the rise of veto Corleone
as well and Robert De Niro I think this
might be my favorite movie that I've
seen him in I don't know he's been in a
lot of great movies but he was [ __ ]
great in that I'm gonna reverse what I
said Saddam had one good son kuse was
good Uday was [ __ ] up okay which
yeah kuse Hussein probably could have
could have been a leader but not Uday no
way Uday was like the perverted version
of [ __ ] no what's his name [ __ ]
Fredo
couldn't trust him around women he was a
rapist you know
stardog 78 said I always believe Kay
lied about having an abortion to get
away from Michael oh that's a
possibility I hadn't considered maybe
yeah that might have been maybe maybe
she just told him not to like to get him
mad so he would like tell her it didn't
matter just her saying that was enough
yeah because that's that's slam a door
on her face that's the last time you see
it but you might see her in part three
we'll see yeah I don't remember if she's
gonna like I said I don't think I'd see
well and I liked that too like where he
just kind of shuts the door in her face
because that calls back to the end of
the first movie where he goes in like
when he's accepted his role as you know
the successor like to his dad and she's
outside in the living room and he slides
the door closed like while they're in
like having a meeting so I liked that it
had that like continuity to it like they
were almost calling back to that scene
from the first one where it's like she's
still like on the outside looking in
kind of yeah you know what I mean so I
think that was really good but yeah I
really really liked
I really liked the just the way that
they juxtaposed the two like you know
what I mean yeah it went back and forth
but I thought it was like thematically
good like the way they the way they went
into and the story of how Vito became
the Godfather was actually like really
interesting yeah like him kind of
you know him well his family got killed
by a mob boss in Sicily right yeah and
so he was like basically left an orphan
and so he
came to the U.S and worked his way up
you know what I mean yeah and then he
eventually goes back to Italy to avenge
his family's [ __ ] murder oh that was
great that was a great scene that was a
great scene like that whole thing where
he comes back and he's like hey oil
sales olive oil yeah yeah
it was good but uh no the way I
interpret the ending is that [ __ ] um
uh Michael realizes that he was just
like his dad that his dad was just as
kinda unwilling
but and he didn't really Revel in it
that much you know I mean it was just
like he
and that it was that command was a
burden
you know yeah that's a good way of
putting it that's a good way of putting
it and then and you could argue that
that's like you said the best person to
do that because it's like you don't want
somebody that's going to enjoy that [ __ ]
because that would be a mess it was a
burden to him right yeah like I don't
like to have to kill you felt that [ __ ]
Fredo I don't like to have to do this
and not the other like it's it kind of
like takes pieces of your soul I guess
but he understood that the necessity of
it yeah and it takes a certain kind of
strength
for it yeah
which and then if you ask me veto made
the right choice
Sonny would not have made it sunny would
have been a dictator and a [ __ ] he
would have got a lot of people killed
all right and yeah because he was
impulsive he didn't really he didn't
really he wanted to go to war all the
time he didn't really want to think
about his actions like you know he would
have gone would have wanted to go to war
all the time he would have been running
after his subordinates wives and
Mistresses which would cause a lot of
[ __ ] problems and uh then you would
have had oh [ __ ] Fredo Fredo would
have just [ __ ] run the [ __ ]
business into a ground a death spiral
and what he would have gotten run over
and and all of his subordinates would
have been killed you had to look at it
from a military standpoint so Michael
was the center Choice the the balanced
measured
guy he does not even really want to be
there but he's got to get this done and
you know like who's the dude that's
sissies pushing the rock up Sisyphus
that's right he's like that's what
they're talking about and he finally
realizes that this [ __ ] is a [ __ ]
burden
because look at how the cow [ __ ] veto
Corleone Don Corleone he he actually
went out happy
eventually because he gave up power
and he died of a heart attack chasing
his little grandson around in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's right in the
[ __ ] of flowers in out in out in the
backyard and uh that was a good death
and that was the best death of mafioso
could ever have
yeah because family was the most
important thing to him right and he was
he he died a successful Dawn
yeah right so you know he didn't get it
it's all family oriented
so that's that's how I that's my take on
all this [ __ ] I thought it was a very
honorable movie
Masterpiece the shots that were done in
this the [ __ ] their period it's a
period piece and they'll give you a big
old long [ __ ] shots down a city
street and it'll look just like the
1930s or the 20s or whatever time period
they're shooting at score [ __ ]
fantastic acting 10 out of 10. there is
no bad acting in this there's really not
everybody in this is amazing that's a
masterpiece both movies masterpiece
so if I want to see three yeah now we
gotta watch part three yeah but like I
said I had forgotten I had forgotten
when we were watching this lesson I was
like I turned it on I was like oh [ __ ]
that's right this is three and a half
hours long you can learn a lot from the
movie it's about leadership
you know you can learn a lot about the
movie
uh you can grow from watching the movie
it's a good movie
I mean there's a lot of it doesn't
necessarily have to be about the mafia
but it's just about anything it applies
to anything in general leadership in
general family in general like just this
kind of like
morality there's morality in it yeah
he's making the same decisions that uh a
head of state would make it's the same
thing yeah
just different tactics Jen Dupont said
Sunny made good sauce he did uh Straw
Dogs 78 said in the book Kay and
Michael's mom have parallel scenes where
they uh pray for the souls of their
husbands oh yeah okay I read the book
but I was a teenager and I don't
remember a single goddamn thing about it
slasher Fred said uh the line keep your
friends close and your enemies closer uh
is a very iconic line yeah that's right
that's and I had forgotten that it came
from this movie
uh Jen says Godfather 3 is a hard watch
yeah I mean I I don't know I haven't
seen it I've I know like some of the
stuff that happens in it but
um yeah I mean I definitely do what is
but like I said I don't remember what
happens with K I was thinking the whole
time because like I said I've seen this
movie but it was a long time ago and I
don't remember anything that happened in
it so I thought K was gonna get plugged
also and then I was like wait would he
go there
yeah I mean he probably was I wasn't
pressed that far though he could divorce
her and get rid of her yeah and his wife
could take care of the kids and she
wasn't like and it's not like she was in
the mob and it's like she could have him
killed or anything yeah no she wasn't an
active threat right so she you could
separate from her for a while and she
might change her mind to come back
because remember because because his
sister changed her mind and came back
yeah what was her name again not Kaya
Connie Connie yeah and I was played by
Talia Shire yeah and I was remarked she
somehow Jenny said she's she that
actress has somehow were made related to
um [ __ ] um Nicholas it's Nicholas
Cage's Aunt okay and she's cute as hell
just a cute cute Italian woman she was
in [ __ ] Rocky and everything yeah
just uh yeah he played Adrian I think
these Adrian and this were like her most
iconic world but she's been in a million
things but I mean those were her two
most famous roles I think just a cute
Italian woman but I forgot that was and
she's actually Francis Ford Coppola's
sister
okay they're all related like the
Coppola family and like I said Nicholas
Cage is her nephew
because I looked it up earlier I was
like I was pretty sure that's what it
was but I wanted to check I was like I
know they're related somehow but I
couldn't remember
uh Zach says I love how willing they
were to use legit dark lighting and make
things kind of hard to see yeah I mean
the the cinematography and all of these
is so beautiful it's just like so it's
so warm it has like that really nice
like gold tone to it well what they do
is they do a lot of classic American and
attack well a classic Italian-American
and American Interiors with brown walls
with white and gold trim there's a lot
of that and then you know just uh so
yeah they don't care about the dark dark
and soft they're uh and the dark is like
really rich yeah yeah it's like a warm
Rich everything looks like it you're
inside of a dab Italian retro Italian
restaurant
but not in a Cheesy way no
and I'm and I love all the shots that
they do because obviously they did shoot
some stuff like really in Italy and I
really liked all of that stuff too like
with all the [ __ ] all that gold um
like sandstone and all that kind of
stuff or whatever it is that was like
really really nice it's an
Italian-American Masterpiece the flick
and um
it's [ __ ] written so far like just
classic literature it's almost like
classic yeah
or like Greek mythology or something
like that which well and there's a
reason why people still adapt those
stories or like do variations of those
stories because they're Universal and
like even nowadays thousands of years
later people still understand yeah all
of those emotions and all of those
events like the way that people feel
about them it's not any different you
could retell this story a thousand years
from now and people would understand it
yeah oh totally
yeah yeah uh Zach says the
cinematographer on these movies uh
Gordon Willis directed an awful Thriller
in the 80s that had Talia Shire in it
called Windows it has a psycho lesbian
stalker I should have got to see that
well I gotta see it I don't think I've
ever heard of that which is crazy who
said let's talk about Zach said that
Zach said this damn Zach we got to have
you on the [ __ ] show bro we need this
new technology today we can have people
calling in sometimes
and Camp guy said his office and scene
one is dark but the lighting is so good
you can see everything yeah yeah I mean
everything in this is and I really liked
the scenes like I said where they had
like Michael and um and Fredo like in
the shot and it's like the big window in
the background that's kind of like
stained glass and especially when you
can like look out and see and it's like
winter outside and you can see all the
snow out there and they're just kind of
like in silhouette or like in Shadow
it's like it looks so so beautiful yeah
what I thought was great was deer in the
beginning they had this waspy ass
[ __ ] Senator talking [ __ ] he didn't
he didn't want these damn Greeks oh yeah
Mafia around and [ __ ] you know and then
eventually they set his ass up [ __ ]
with that dead hooker and it's looking
and then see now yeah that's the thing
because can they killed one of their own
hookers for that [ __ ] here's the thing
though like I was reading the Wikipedia
page and and stuff and it was saying or
I was reading some other reviews of it
and it was basically saying I don't know
if it came out and said that like the
mob had set that Senator up like with
the dead hooker and everything I thought
that was the implication though because
that's how I thought yeah because he was
there and he's like well he had been to
that girl before he knew her and he's
and he's like I don't remember how it
happened okay but I think that like the
way that I was reading about it at least
like on some of the um like the other
plot synopses was that that had just
happened like that they didn't set it up
okay he did it that he just really did
do it okay so I thought that they set it
up that's what I thought like I thought
they drugged him
if it was the CIA that's what they would
have done well that's what I'm saying
well that's well that's what I thought
right and because it so it was just dumb
luck I'm not sure but I'm just saying I
thought the implication was that they
had set that up yeah and specifically
because he said I don't remember how it
happened so I thought that they had done
it because it was one of their I mean it
was one of their guys
uh brothels right and so I thought yeah
that'd be like pretty good I mean yeah
you'd have to and then Tom comes in and
goes she has no relatives nobody knew
that she was here so you know we're good
yeah uh but I was like well isn't that
convenient right but he said he'd been
with her a couple times yeah yeah and I
was I was under the implication that the
mob had killed that house I thought they
would have set him up and see Jen said
that too I thought it was a setup yeah
so did I yeah because I said that would
be too much of a coincidence but here's
the thing man they did that and they
were like oh lucky yes here's the thing
though you got to give the Italian mob
credit where credit was due they in
general protected uh women and children
they were kind of Civilian women and
children were off limits
um yeah they ran brothels but they
didn't kill any of those girls you know
for far as I was concerned they tended
to like those girls so I thought that
was kind of out of character that I was
kind of like wait they killed that girl
to set that Center up it says that's
pretty [ __ ] hardcore that was kind of
out of character for the mob right so
maybe they weren't really that type
so maybe he did do it so he must have
done it yeah but see I've thought I
don't know I just thought it was a setup
because I said well they needed some
dirt on him and he'd been kind of like a
[ __ ] to Michael did you like come in
there like swinging his dick around and
I was like okay bud you know what I mean
about the whole like Vegas casino thing
like the licenses that he wanted
so I was like oh well it just it would
have seemed like too much of a
coincidence for that Senator to you know
one of the things that
people don't realize is that the Italian
mob kind of went out of fashion over
time
because they weren't that ruthless
um Colombian drug cartels later on in
the 80s kind of
out did them in a lot of ways they were
willing to do a lot of [ __ ] that the
Italian guys weren't willing to do and
those Italian guys got so wealthy During
the period that these movies came out is
that they
they were able to go straight they they
didn't really need to be criminals
anymore they owned so much property
they owned so many restaurants and
[ __ ] businesses that they didn't
really need criminal activity anymore a
lot of them just outgrew it
they were replaced by other guys so that
I was just kind of going like damn
that's kind of out of character for the
Italian mob to kill a hooker well Camp
guy says she OD'd accidentally and they
made use of the situation okay now you
see that would make that make some more
sense that it was a deception yeah she
OD'd and then they made it and then they
made it
murdered her yeah that makes a lot more
because I was like that seems [ __ ] up
if they would just kill her for that
yeah yeah like you know because it's
like you know the oh yeah the women and
the brothels that was their I mean they
that was like part of their business so
why would they yeah and they had to have
loyalty for the girls Camp guy said just
a guess but that that makes sense though
yeah and you can't force a woman into a
brothel
they have to be willing okay so you have
to have loyalty from them and the only
way to do that is that if they're making
money and they're being treated well
okay so it makes a lot more sense that
shio deed and then they set it up to
make it look like he had killed him so
when he wakes up that makes it that fits
more in the character of of the of the
Italian mob they were deceivers they
would use deception you know yeah they'd
do that [ __ ] right but yeah like I
said because that would have been really
[ __ ] up if they just go because she
didn't do anything yeah because the
other girls would know I mean that would
that would [ __ ] up the Loyalty type deal
yeah you think all the other girls yeah
like holy [ __ ] we gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here because it's like what if they
decide what to get us to get us that way
like to [ __ ] over somebody else you know
what I mean yeah that wouldn't be good
right your morale is going to be really
cool exactly so so yeah that actually
makes more sense I don't know if that's
what actually happens but it does make
more sense I'm just saying that most of
the plot synopsis I read said that he
had just done that
or because in the books if you go back
and look at uh [ __ ] um the dude who
was Luca brazi
one of his best hitmen his backstory was
pretty [ __ ] ruthless he threw his own
baby into a damn furnace because it was
part Irish that his girlfriend was Irish
and he was not inhabited and based on
that act he became
the mafia's version of the devil okay he
was the devil and um
they used him as a as an assassin but
they didn't like him
he was not a popular person he was
a pariah in a certain way but yeah it
was just he was it was he was like
Zeus unleashing in the Kraken you know
what I'm talking about right after he
was like he was he was that okay because
uh the Italians are family based it's a
Latin culture you know growing up in a
Latin culture myself down in Brazil now
it's family oriented over and over again
they talk about family
you could have a wife but you don't
leave your wife you can have Mistresses
though but don't leave your wife and
your children they they were family
oriented and don't make it look bad
everything had to be traditional yeah
they were right wig
they were right-wing conservative well
the thing about it I mean even though
they were doing illegal [ __ ] and we're
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] and having people
killed and stuff like that they did have
an a code of honor they weren't just
doing stuff well because they were
running a business they were trying to
make money for everybody even though it
was a business on the wrong side of the
law perhaps but you can't just have
somebody out there killing people at
random or doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] or like
yeah you know because that's that's
gonna [ __ ] up everyone's like ability to
make money yeah and and they're running
a business they're running these
businesses to to support and feed their
families okay so these are these are
Family Guys now you also have to you
also have here's another thing though
which is something had to be pointed out
and this is just the way the times were
also
they were ethnocentric there was a big
difference between an Italian person and
a non-italian it kind of showed the
Anglo people that were marrying into the
Italian family [ __ ] they kind of
didn't approve of them that the women
well Connie brings that one yeah and
then didn't Fredo bring that one yeah
the Fredo brought the [ __ ] floozy
checked she was hot but she couldn't
stay sober and embarrassed and
um and and they could and the Italians
at this point consider black people just
to be Marx that's who you sold your
drugs to and they came out and said well
they're animals anyway
so you know they're not they're
ethnocentric okay they're they're very
because they're family Centric and their
families were Italian okay so that's
just the way they were yeah they were
very like tribal and yeah yeah yeah
Camp guy says Roth gives Michael
influence and casinos in Cuba announces
it to all the families then Michael
kills him is that correct well see Roth
was [ __ ] Michael over though like
behind his back and dealing with Roth
was kind of going out of the Italian
thing
because Roth was just Jewish he was
Jewish yeah he was a mob boss too he was
a Jew yeah no they but they respected
him they respected him but uh but like
but like all Sonny's and not sunny but
the other guy said he said he said he
they always they always respected Roth
but they never trusted him yeah he
wasn't Italian right well and he was one
he was one of the ones that was trying
to get Michael assassinated I mean he
was behind that um the assassination
attempts where not only Michael but also
Kay almost got killed because they shot
in the bedroom windows yeah so when he
found out that Roth was behind it and
then later on he found out that Fredo
knew about it too although Fredo like I
said said that he didn't know that it
was going to be an assassination attempt
he just thought it was going to be like
some little back dealing like behind
here but because Michael didn't really
want to invest in Cuba because he
thought that the Revolution was going to
happen and he was right about that so he
thought it was like a dangerous
proposition there's a lot of accuracies
in this tale I mean if you think
the Italians were the only Mafia you're
[ __ ] wrong the Irish Americans had
their own Mafia everybody had a mom so
did the Jews Jewish Americans had their
own Mafia too
uh so but there was some crossover they
worked with both
they worked with with Italian Guys and
Jewish guys
but uh
yeah [ __ ] a good Italian a good
Jewish Mafia movie with [ __ ] uncut
gems Adam Sandler yeah [ __ ] great
it's a different time that movie was so
good yeah I want to see I gotta buy that
[ __ ] I don't own that one
uh if somebody sends it to me we will
[ __ ] do a store we'll do a [ __ ]
review because we did talk about a
little bit because we saw that in the
theater yeah it came out and it's like
yeah Adam Sandler's best movie and it's
a great it's a great gangster movie
and it didn't didn't get any [ __ ]
play
I guess the kind of Jewish gangsters we
can't talk about that well everybody
talked about it when it first came out
but then like it seemed like everybody
like because I kind of thought that it
was gonna get um they talked about like
oh maybe you get nominated for like some
awards and I think it did but
I don't know I feel like then everybody
just kind of forgot about it but
Taylor's best flick yeah I mean
like I said good gangster [ __ ]
can act when he wants to I don't really
I don't really like a lot of his movies
because I don't like this comedies
aren't that good no it's not me
that was that was the [ __ ] the The
Godfather that was the Jewish Godfather
it pretty much was yeah that [ __ ] was
good like I said that is one of the most
anxiety-inducing movies
me too of him [ __ ] gambling with
other people's money like just my
stomach hurt like literally the whole
time I'm watching it I was like oh my
God I don't want to see that [ __ ] I
don't like it's not one bit I got it and
it was based on a real story the guy who
wrote that story he's writing it about
his dad his dad yeah Jewish guy down the
in the New York [ __ ] Diamond District
who was just [ __ ] people over and
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] with his money I
mean because you're just watching him
just going Jesus Christ dude do you have
like a [ __ ] a death wish or what and
he made it we made it until the very end
well yeah yeah he made it till the end
of the movie it's a very Irish got a
hold of his ass
but it was good oh my God
uh Straw Dogs 78 said Once Upon a Time
in America was about Jewish Mobsters
great movie
I don't remember that one Tammy said Tom
Hardy plays a Jewish mafia boss in peaky
blinders I've still been it's a that's a
series I've actually been wanting to
watch that series for a long time it's
like I've had numerous people like
recommended Tom Hardy man is my favorite
actor man he's my newest favorite actor
he that dude can do anything
yeah I'm really impressed with that guy
yeah he's awesome yeah Ben says uncut
gems is amazing it's a [ __ ] amazing
the main character lies two cheats or
steals from literally every single other
character yeah yeah yeah and he's just
like totally I'm just like do you really
think how long do you think you're gonna
be able to get away with that that's
what was so like anxiety induced I'm
just like just stop it and the dude is
every negative stereotype but
but that's what that character was man
well it works because he doesn't come
across as he doesn't come across as a
collection of stereotypes he comes
across as a real guy right yeah yeah who
just happened to kind of be like that
yeah yeah you know what I mean he
doesn't come which is like a hard that's
a that's a hard uh people were pissed
off about that but Sandler's Jewish and
[ __ ] this is what he wants to do
that's a hard line to walk but I think
he did it successfully like I said he
can act when he wants to I was impressed
man one of my favorites one of my
favorite movies I really like we saw it
in the theater we were blown away we're
like God I was like goddamn those and
there was a lot of [ __ ] symbolism and
in it and everything you know and
[ __ ]
the basketball player is selling the
[ __ ] Furby the Furby [ __ ] yeah
I gotta see that [ __ ] again yeah we
really need to see that yeah uh Ben says
peaky blinders is great yeah I'm gonna
get around to it seriously literally
even a couple years ago I had somebody
represent it's like oh my God you have
to watch peaky blinders it's like I said
it's a series and I was like oh yeah I
gotta get around to that and then
literally the other day I was watching
uh what's that other Channel that I like
with the Halloween girl on it uh Jade
the Libra and her and her husband
they're like we've just watched the
entire run of peaky blonde blinders and
they were like so excited about it and I
was just like [ __ ] now I gotta [ __ ]
watch because it's over now so I don't
know how many seasons it was but I was
like okay well now I can watch the whole
thing because it's like complete uh Jen
says Tom Hardy is amazing yeah please
review Bronson I think we did we did it
I'm pretty sure we reviewed it because
um Sophie yeah a friend of the show
comes over she's gonna be coming over in
a couple of months gonna get her ass on
the [ __ ] show with us like last time
yeah we'll see so she doesn't check it
out run off she did a live stream with
what she's got y'all were [ __ ]
chatting her up too much too many dudes
were flirting with her so she's gonna
she ran away
yeah yeah poor so but yeah uh she sent
us Bronson so yeah we were it was
probably like a watch file back probably
like a year or two I want to say but
yeah I love bronzer yeah I thought we
reviewed it I'm pretty I'm pretty sure
we did did okay yeah yeah great movie
yeah we did yeah we reviewed it because
I I remember talking about how it was
kind of shot and the Clockwork Orange
style yeah yeah
um Motif you know which it's almost like
the sequel to [ __ ] records but it's real
yeah this is
it's about [ __ ] England's most
notorious [ __ ] convict
great flick that dude's alone yeah but
but it's a fun movie though yeah but
Hardy Tom Hardy he's great man he can
gain all kinds of weight and [ __ ] get
big doing steroid cycles to become Bane
or [ __ ] become these other dudes and
then he'll get skinny again and do
another character and everything I think
he's just a great character
made a great Mad Max
um everything I've seen him and I
enjoyed him we played Reggie and Ronnie
cray
um just that was like maybe yeah was
that movie called legend legend yeah
that was a good movie too and you know
the British are the best actors they got
the best acting schools they're they're
[ __ ] really good
um some of the American Studios they
have the big budget a lot of skills but
you got to have British actors in there
American actors are just
well you know not All-American because
there's a lot of good American actors
too but I'm gonna say that the British
are the most versatile yeah I kind of
feel it they're better I mean they they
do like I said they take it goes back to
Shakespearean [ __ ] and they take the
craft extremely seriously they you know
most Americans get on there because the
casting couch they get [ __ ]
weinsteined into a movie Eric Weinstein
well or just because they look like sign
off and you get in the movie that's it
that's all it is yeah I think they're
people are more concerned about what
they look like rather than like their
acting Talent maybe Zach says fun fact I
learned recently is one of the potential
directors for the first Godfather was
Sydney Fury who did the entity in the
ipcrest file Imagine That movie yeah I
don't know if that would have worked out
so well again we should because honestly
didn't well we talked about the movie
on our very first episode but we didn't
we talked about the movie in relation to
like the real case right I kind of feel
like we talked about that so I don't
know if we've ever
just reviewed the movie yeah I feel like
we probably have he said he's gonna go
look at Bronson our Bronson review after
this show I'm pretty sure it's there I
think we did I'm pretty sure we did it
because I remember it man get back with
us and remind us but I'm pretty sure I
mean we've done like a million movies so
sometimes it's hard for me to remember
yeah because I do movie reviews too like
on my other little channels and stuff so
sometimes I lose track of like what
movies are reviewing because we've been
doing this a long time so uh Ben says
Once Upon a Time in America is great too
that's what he was talking about that
was like a Jewish the Jewish monster
yeah so everybody says yeah we should
watch that as well I've heard of it but
I don't think I've ever seen it unless I
was like a kid Straw Dogs 78 said Tom
Hardy was great in the drop with James
Gandolfini underrated nobody really
talks about it didn't see it that's
another one so let me write that down
right because it's like I don't think
I've even heard of that okay
we need to look at like Tom Tom Hardy's
like Wikipedia page and like check out
all this because I'm sure every other
stuff that I haven't seen every role
I've seen him play I was [ __ ] I was
impressed it was like God damn it dude's
good man
and what's funny is that he started off
as basically what we would call Pretty
Boy look pretty boy yeah
um he looked like [ __ ]
just a little skinny pretty boy and then
he got [ __ ] big and he started doing
other [ __ ] roles and just uh no I
just I think he's a great actor he's a
great actor
also Tammy said he was great and [ __ ]
Venom yeah I thought he made a great
Venom you know
his accent isn't always on point but
it's good enough
good enough yeah it's fine yeah it's
good enough Tammy says uh you have to
watch Lawless with Tom Hardy in it never
seen that one yeah that's another one I
hated right now okay what was that about
let me keep this over here because I'm
just like writing down 78 said yeah the
entity in The Shining yeah that was the
first show that we did yeah
so we did entity already well I see a
little time ago we didn't we kind of
talked about the movie but we kind of
talked about the Doris bither case okay
like in relation to the movies
we need to do a proper entity review
I if we haven't I gotta I gotta check
I'm pretty sure we haven't
uh it's based on real life Moonshiners
that's that's right up here that's right
oh yeah I love that [ __ ] yeah
um has anyone wrote it down yeah yeah
okay has anyone seen Tom Hardy as Capone
yeah I was hearing about that like I
remember seeing like all the um the
trailers and stuff for it and it looks
good but
Tammy said yes you guys did Bronson okay
I thought we had yeah we did it I
thought we had but um but yeah so all
right no I got a big man crush on on
[ __ ] Hardy he does yeah
I'm like man that [ __ ] you know
he impresses me
yeah he has like a great uh range he has
a great range he's doing [ __ ] Reggie
and Ronnie Craig they're two twins and
[ __ ] one and they're very different
one's kind of a spell [ __ ]
gangster dude the other one's a big
[ __ ] brutish gay dude you know what I
mean and they're he [ __ ] he sold me
and I was like man that's that's a
[ __ ] badass gangster story he tells
the [ __ ] Italian mob that he likes
Italian boys
that he had one all bent up
what's going on and the tabs are like oh
okay
that [ __ ] would not normally fly with
the Italians but they just kind of like
well okay all right they would have
Associated that with like prison culture
you know what I mean uh all right
Tammy says uh LOL I've got a big woman
crush on Hardy
yeah he's pretty he's awesome he's a
very good actor very good actor [ __ ]
just with his how he delivers the
character and just his physicality how
much
what drastic changes he can do at a
physical level like I said I will always
respect an actor for going all in like
that yeah in such a short period of time
yeah I mean that's terrible for your
head like I said I'm sure that's a
really really bad for y'all it's like
I'm sure like yeah they have money and
they get a lot of money so I'm sure they
have like supervision obviously yeah um
so you know they're not just doing it
willy-nilly but you know hopefully they
have like doctors and nutritionists and
stuff that are like watching out for
their [ __ ] but still I mean still
drastic changes like that are just
really not
really not good but we trained for Bay
and evidently he was really upset
because he would have had to gain so
much weight
to become that character and I saw some
clips of him in the gym training and
throwing barrels and throwing weights
and [ __ ] picking things up and
I don't know what he was on man he to
gain that much weight
in the amount of time
he got pretty big for Bane
and uh it could
he had to have been on trend
Tran could do that but then to come back
down off of that
and and he returned to kind of normal
proportions
although he he wasn't that huge it's
just that
I think my proportions might have been
bigger than his actually
out of Bane but he sold himself as being
even bigger Larger than Life
and that's part of the damn because some
of that has to do with like how you
carry yourself how you know how you're
standing how they shoot you with the
camera yeah what you're wearing the
voice his voice and stuff and what he
was wearing he sold himself as being
much bigger than he really actually he
really is I mean they have stills from
him shooting all that behind scenes he's
not that big
proportionally I think my proportions
are bigger than his but when you look at
that movie he looks [ __ ] intimidating
well like I said it's yeah it's all kind
of like angles they shoot him from that
that helps too Zach says I wonder what
the results are like whenever Christian
Bale gets blood work done imagine being
the poor phlebotomist right yeah the
same kind of thing it's like hey I'm
gonna be in The Machinist and I'm just
gonna like live on gum for six months
and weigh 80 pounds and then I'm gonna
like play didn't Christian Bale didn't
he play
I want to say didn't he play Dick Cheney
and he get and he got like super fat and
he looked just like dick he really did
we saw that [ __ ] in the theater yeah
and it was that was a good movie yeah he
was fun to watch
fun to watch yeah it was called device
or something Dick Cheney yeah the Dick
Cheney's story
pretty much yeah it was kind of well it
was kind of about that whole time period
but yeah it was it was about Dick Cheney
and he gained yeah he got super fat yeah
and I was just kind of like he was
unrecognizable
yeah advice
that was yeah we saw that in the theater
that was good actually Jen said your
drinks always look refreshing they are
refreshing it's just tea with vodka yeah
this is It's iced tea with vodka yeah
because hey it's the weekend yeah
although we we drink on the weekdays too
so who are we trying to kid yeah
yeah he was great as Cheney yeah I
thought he was too like he looked like
spookily like him I thought really he
delivered it the way he delivered those
lives it sounded like dude Cheney talk I
mean I kind of want to see that again
now I remember really liking that movie
like it like it [ __ ] I thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious it was kind of like a
black comedy wasn't it kinda yeah it was
kind of a black comedy I feel like but
it was kind of like a docudrama too yeah
you know but it was also kind of funny
like yeah talking about how Dick Cheney
got got into his position and and really
there wasn't there's not a lot what's
funny is that you had these people that
get into government power up in
Washington DC
and they portray themselves as like very
important like they but no a lot of them
come from pretty humble beginnings
there's not much to them
they're almost actors into themselves
actually well the thing about a lot of
times the people that are kind of like
that you would see is like oh they're
important or something like that it's
like a lot of times they just got lucky
they're just like in the right place at
the right time and there's not a lot
so
uh Jen says vodka is good every day it
is yeah it is it's good it's a
flavorless
liquor that you can put into anything
yeah we keep in the in the refrigerator
in our little mini fridge up here uh in
our little break room right there we
have a big gallon jug of tea and a big
gallon jug of lemonade
I was gonna say last night for us tell
them Jenny he made iced coffee yeah with
vodka while we were while we were
watching Godfather too
caramel and vodka yeah caramel and vodka
of Dunkin Donuts
iced coffee blend
grains is what I used
poured them over ice in the [ __ ]
coffee ninja in the coffee in the coffee
ninja
there's a [ __ ] okay there's a series
they were delicious there's a series of
[ __ ] uh kitchen appliances that are
called ninja well yeah that's the brand
one of them is a food processor that
have called a ninja yeah we have one of
these so like we have a little one and a
big one this the other one I have is a
[ __ ] coffee ninja it'll make coffee
by the cup it'll make espresso it'll
[ __ ] I mean yeah it'll froth up your
[ __ ] milk it does all this [ __ ]
cool [ __ ] that sounds dirty but here's
how [ __ ] weird this is a ninja is an
assassin yeah
back in the day when Kawasaki came out
of that motorcycle people were calling
it The Ninja and [ __ ] Kawasaki's like
wait a minute hold on why are we calling
this thing a ninja that's like saying
hit man okay but that's cool too
only in America imagine if you [ __ ]
in Japan they got a machine called the
[ __ ] coffee hit man and they got it
dude
not gonna lie with a gun and [ __ ] we'll
see coffee hit man no for real like now
we should does anybody have a lot
Somebody's gotta have this does anybody
have a line of coffees yeah like well
because espresso and stuff that's very
Italian right yeah so you have a line of
like espresso that's like Hitman
espresso torpedo somebody's got a house
yeah yeah he's a torpedo yeah they could
even have a Godfather themed line yeah
right yeah like you know you'd have to
like skirt around copyright somehow like
you couldn't really you couldn't use the
same font or nothing like that but you
know
Corleone coffee or some [ __ ] like that
then you got another [ __ ]
[ __ ] 45 Six Guns and [ __ ] it's called
Outlaw coffee yeah that [ __ ] would still
sell here in the United States well yeah
well the thing about it is like the back
of a [ __ ]
horse with [ __ ] his guns and his
[ __ ] cowboy hat and [ __ ] called [ __ ]
outlaw
well you know that there's you know that
there's a horror themed coffee line
actually they have a shop I don't know
if it's still open but they had a shop
in Atlanta but um they sell it like all
over the country it's like they have a
zombie flavor and looks like that their
design is like really really cool
actually when we went to that horror
convention scream Fest or whatever the
[ __ ] it's called a couple years back
they had a big booth there and we're
like giving coffee away for free and man
it was delicious but yeah
um we did do an episode about ninjas
ninjas yeah we did didn't we it was
called bullshito well wait was that a
separate one because I thought we we did
the bullshito one and that was about
like [ __ ] uh ashita Kim and like all
that yeah the black hands inside or
whatever yeah black fight Dragon black
but I thought we did a separate one on
ninjas or did we not we did we all just
like put it together I think it was all
in one maybe Bushido which is [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Straw Dogs 78 said there's a Death Wish
coffee see I figured that they probably
had well because if you're gonna do like
that kind of you know uh Artisan kind of
coffee like small batch
you need something that's gonna
you know attract attention I mean don't
they have one that's called what the
[ __ ] is it called Death something that
has like a skull and crossbones and it's
supposed to be like super super strong
or something you know what I mean yeah
you're saying ninja weapons come from
farm tools look there were no ninjas we
went ahead and talked about that there
weren't any ninjas well not in the way
that the movies no
it was a legend
Assad says hey Tom hey Jen uh do you
know about GE Kincaid and his cave no
that does not sound familiar yeah but if
you fill me in on the details I will
yeah look that up
actually you know what uh what the show
you'll be excited that our show on
Wednesday night is going to be about
like is going to be UFO kind of stuff oh
really so okay good you'll probably like
that all right and shut it down Ben says
mummies yeah I don't know
Zach says uh oh also Francis Ford
Coppola is probably going to be
releasing a new movie soon a sci-fi
movie called Mega Megapolis okay and I
guess he's self-financed basically the
whole thing hmm well [ __ ] so he's making
it like exactly the way it was okay I'm
interested to see that interested to see
that
um all right so I guess we're gonna sign
off yeah so because okay so tomorrow's
Monday and that means we're doing a
haunting Mondays if you're new here that
means we're going to talk about an
episode of a haunting like from what
channel did that start out on a e
Discovery I don't know whatever the hell
the ghost hunting show or the ghost show
so for some reason we're really into
that show and we did uh a lot of
episodes about it back in the old days
and it's like we recently like started
redoing that so we usually would ask for
recommendations for which episode to do
uh Tom Sykes gave us a recommendation to
do Ghost Soldier because he said he
rewatched it yeah and it wasn't as bad
as he remembered we'll do it so I guess
we'll watch that one and we'll kind of
like see how let's see how that goes I
kind of remember it but we haven't seen
in a long time so it'll probably be go
Soldier try to check that [ __ ] she
inherited a picture of a [ __ ] god of
a guy [ __ ] in a uniform or she
founded a garage yeah and she put it up
on the wall and it and it brought and it
started haunting her the picture was
Haunting here God damn it from the
garage sale all right so we're gonna do
that tomorrow so come on by at 6 p.m
Eastern Standard time for us to talk
about a haunting thank you for dropping
by today and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow good night